[Music]
an absolutely astonishing trailer for
the Godzilla sequel king of the monsters
just dropped yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I'm
going to explain all about the new
monsters in the Gosselaar 2 trailer and
I'll be revealing their special
connection with Milly Bobby Brown and
Vera Farmiga x' characters this image of
a frozen King Ghidorah is simply
stunning now we've known since we saw
those paintings were dragon-like
creature in the end credits of Kong
Skull Island that King Ghidorah would be
appearing in this film that this
gorgeous image of the three-headed
winged serpent suspended in icy
Antarctica is still a delightful
surprise and that shot of him spreading
his wings with the lightning behind him
is another stunner because not only is
Ghidorah 's body capable of conducting
electrical currents but he also heats
water vapor in the air creating a
localized but devastating storm system
with thunder and lightning as he travels
Ghidorah was a powerful enemy of
Godzilla Mothra and Rodan when he first
appeared in Ghidorah the three-headed
monster in the 1964 Toho movie the
monstrous dragon was an extraterrestrial
being that hatched from an egg which
initially appeared to be a meteor
Ghidorah attempted to take over the
earth until Mothra stood up to him with
Godzilla and Rodan eventually deciding
to team up with her to defeat Ghidorah
and send him back to space so I wonder
if the filmmakers have gone with an
alien backstory fuga dora in the new
movie then there's this majestic shot of
godzilla rising from the sea and
unleashing his atomic breath and as if
that wasn't enough it's followed by a
stunning shot of a beautiful
bioluminescent Mothra in what looks like
a waterfall spreading her wings until
she fills the full screen with her
wingspan which measures over 800 feet
and shout out to the haunting music to
boosie's clair de lune which works
beautifully in this moment and
throughout the trailer as the name
suggests Mothra is a moth-like creature
that is often been portrayed as a savior
and according to the monarch Sciences
website this version is a devastating
guardian angel whose beta wave
bioluminescence can be projected through
the intricate patterns on its wings and
weaponized into blinding godrays Mothra
is one of the movie studio Toho's most
popular kaiju and it surpassed only by
Godzilla in the
of movies that she's appeared in she did
go up against Godzilla in the 1964 movie
Mothra versus Godzilla and also in 1992
s Godzilla vs. Mothra next up is Rodin a
type of Pteranodon that first appeared
on the big screen in Toho studios 1956
movie Rodin I was initially a foe of
Godzilla's in the 1964 movie Ghidorah
the three-headed monster in this film
Rodin has been lying dormant in the Isla
de Moana volcano and we see this fire
demon return to life in the trailer as
it sweeps over a city leaving a trail of
destruction behind it and that's because
it's 870 foot wingspan creates a sonic
thunderclap capable of leveling entire
cities as it flies overhead by the way
this gorgeous but devastating image
really reminded me of Game of Thrones
speaking of which one new 15 could that
line have been any more Game of Thrones
I feel like all Charles dance is missing
with that dark high-neck top is wearing
is his hand of the king badge details of
Charles dancers character haven't been
revealed yet but I wonder if he's part
of the mysterious organization that's
kidnapped money Bobby Brown and Vera
Farmiga x' characters and plans to use
the creatures for its own ends obviously
any movie featuring Millie Bobby Brown
and monsters is going to draw
comparisons with stranger things and
this particular image here of Brown
reaching out to Mothra while her mother
stands behind her reminded me of 11
confronting the shadow monster with
hopper by the looks of this scene though
Browns encounter with the creature seems
a lot less life-threatening than her
monstrous face to face in stranger
things in fact speaking to e w Brown
said that wants her character Madison
understands Godzilla there's some mutual
respect for each other and she also
added that Madison has been taught not
to be scared of any monsters I imagine
that will be because of her
paleobiologist mother who works for the
monster tracking organization monarch
indeed according to actress Vera Farmiga
the character she plays has figured out
a way to communicate with the creatures
and potentially control them using their
bio acoustics on a sonar level in
contrast to the shot with Mothra this
other image here seems a lot more
menacing because although you might have
thought that was Godzilla in the back
ground look really carefully and you'll
see three eyes meaning that's actually
the three-headed Ghidorah looming over
brown I think Browns character Madison
will be one of the keys to defeating
Ghidorah alongside Godzilla and the
other monsters and given far migas words
throughout the trailer
I feel the movies going to have a people
are the real monsters vibe our world is
changing the mass extinction we feared
has already begun and we are the cause
we are the infection in fact Farmiga
said that for her the film is about
saving the environment so what do you
think about the Godzilla king of the
monsters trailer and did you spot any
other interesting details or have any
theories about the movie let me know
your thoughts below and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up is always appreciated
tapleft to check out my monster movie
playlist or tap write for another video
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time you PKA movie
lovers